during this global pandemic the world
for the most part has looked to the
World Health Organization for guidance
the World Health Organization launches a
collaborative project to find a vaccine
and treatments the World Health
Organization warning young people
they're not invincible the World Health
Organization officially announced that
this is a global pandemic instead it's
found controversy when President Trump
does find fault in handling the pandemic
is the World Health Organization you
know right now there they're literally a
pipe organ for China that's the way of
view he accused the body of being too
trusting of China's assertions that it
had the virus under control they not
only need to answer to the needs of over
100 member states but the whims and
politics of the countries and
organizations that donate the lion's
share of their budget this is the story
of how the w-h-o tried to please the
world and ended up losing its biggest
backer the World Health Organization was
founded in 1948 by the also newly formed
United Nations Czechoslovakia
jugo-slavia Denmark Greece Poland
Hungary and many other nations have
benefited from WH ol headquartered in
Geneva they were tasked to mandate and
coordinate health policy initial vision
for World Health Organization was not
only to make it an important agency
focusing on health issues disease issues
disease outbreaks but to try to create a
form of international cooperation
collaboration that would bind the
nations together and in the coming
decades the w-h-o has taken on a
dizzying amount of missions from
world-altering ones like the eradication
of smallpox and the identification of
HIV to awareness campaigns like safe
driving suicide prevention and
anti-smoking psays
well there are several main roles so one
is to what they call its normative role
which means it sets standards for
medical matters throughout the world and
it has an important role in providing
technical support to low and middle
income countries in order to tackle all
of those initiatives the w-h-o has
become an incredibly complex
organization there are six regional
offices around the world in Congo
Denmark America India Egypt and the
Philippines all of which report to the
headquarters in Geneva each of which has
its own motor functioning
Jurek radix staff and the like the
balance of authority between the
regional offices and the headquarters in
Geneva it's always been slightly
problematic to meet get them all reading
from the same page when they have
different regional constituents and
within those regional constituencies are
150 country offices in order to run all
of those offices requires a great deal
of money originally in the form of
assessed contributions or dues by the
member states assessments were
determined by the overall GDP or
economic strength of that particular
country and this population with some
formula worked out and that formula
worked for a while
member states paid their dues the w-h-o
provided guidance for health issues
around the world
but over the last three decades that
amount of money declined and is now only
about 20% of its overall budget today
the w-h-o is mostly funded by voluntary
contributions with the United States
being by far the highest paying
contributor followed by the organization
started by this guy if anything kills
over 10 million people in the next few
decades its most likely to be a highly
infectious virus rather than a war and
when and where the w-h-o gets its money
from influences so much about what it
can do and the Gates Foundation can stay
through our extra
budgetary funding but like so much
invested in polio no one can tell us not
to do that and that has made w-h-o a
very unbalanced and complicated
organization that unbalanced of
complicated bureaucracy has consistently
been one of the World Health
Organization's biggest criticisms but
they've also been criticized for how
they've reacted to the past two major
epidemics before kovat 19 we've now seen
another outbreak of SARS and potentially
we've seen a cluster and transmission of
the SARS virus in 2003 was SARS the
w-h-o was criticized for overreacting to
the disease which only had 774 known
deaths but ended up costing East Asian
countries over 20 billion dollars in
lost GDP hotels tour agencies and travel
companies are reported to have suffered
huge losses during the outbreak that led
to an under reaction in the response to
the Ebola epidemic in West Africa in
2014 the big decision before them
whether to label this worst-ever Ebola
outbreak a quote public health emergency
of international concern it didn't get a
grip on the situation and it delayed in
calling this public health emergency of
international concern the head of the
World Health Organization Margaret Chan
so she has she had been dealing with
outbreaks like bird flu like stars
shouldn't she have been handling this
better and so it was a general mess
which led to many investigations
afterwards about the wh shows very slow
and inefficient and inadequate response
so with the overreaction to SARS and
under reaction to Ebola kovat 19 was a
chance for the w-h-o to finally get
things right and initially everyone
seemed happy with their performance
Kovan 19 is a real threat it is a real
threat to everyone on the planet
it took the WHL one month to declare
kovin 19 an international health
emergency compare that to the four
months it took them to call Ebola in
international
health emergency and Trump who
originally praised China and the wh OHS
response to the pandemic so far I think
John has been trying to be or at least
they seem to be trying to be somewhat
transparent with us he later turned on a
dime blaming not only China for the
pandemic but the w-h-o as well
the w-h-o willingly took China's
assurances to face value and they took
it just at face value and defended the
actions of the Chinese government even
praising China for its so-called
transparency I don't think so this was
partially a response to the w-h-o
director-general Tadros at Anan Gabri a
sis's constant praise of China during
the pandemic I will praise China again
and again because its actions actually
helped in reducing the spread of
coronavirus to other countries China as
well as critics of trumps administration
say Trump shifted the blame for domestic
political reasons to divert attention
from his catastrophic failure to address
the crisis in America whether it be from
initially downplaying the virus this big
vast land of ours this great country of
ours move 240 cases most of those people
are going to be fine to touting unproven
treatments a drug called
hydroxychloroquine and it's shown very
encouraging very very encouraging early
results I think it's gonna be I think
it's gonna be great all while the death
rate in America surpassed that of the
rest of the world and even though there
are accusations that China has not been
transparent about their numbers of kovat
19 Tadros and the w-h-o were presented
with an impossible decision the w-h-o
has no power of enforcement they cannot
dispatch a team against their country's
wishes they're dependent on data coming
out of that country with a presumption
that countries will cooperate in no
situation could the WHL please both the
US
and China and that resulted in Trump
taking punitive action today I'm
instructing my administration to halt
funding of the World Health Organization
while a review is conducted to assess
mismanaging and covering up the spread
of the corona virus and remember that
chart for who funds the w-h-o it's not
just a huge loss for the organization
but for poorer countries around the
globe every one of the essential
functions of the WHL
would be immediately challenged and
threatened if not stopped and while
America has the CDC to create their own
guidelines and best practices countries
and other parts of the world don't have
those resources and are desperately
dependent upon the w-h-o to provide
equipment information interventions and
now those will reach seriously
challenged if not stopped completely so
where does this leave the World Health
Organization right now apparently it's
not up to them but us reminded of a
quote by Larry Gustin who was one of the
international health experts it's very
important in the whu-oh he has said the
world has gotten the w-h-o that it
deserves the world has created this
organization with all its faults flaws
inconsistencies and inefficiencies can
the world wake up can this crisis forced
the world to say we really do need a
well-functioning and truly neutral World
Health body that will not be beholden to
various financial interests political
interest and that of crisis can come
federal disaster but hope and a new
beginning will the world let it
[Music]
you